seems like a lot of people are upset at
fresh and fit right now it's going
mainstream
yeah
the shade room everybody's sending
everybody yeah everybody everybody
somebody says i'm super corny they said
yo y'all gotta reply gotham needs you i
was like
calm
and some folks got mad after the last
video and they're like you guys are
[ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] you didn't
just leave a google review no that's
that's what we did and we told you that
that broom is garbage that's what we did
we left the google review read this
read it
where's bruce in miami
all they got are dust badges cans yeah
yeah yeah yeah do you know why i left
that review
on their building
give you guys a quick resume because a
lot of y'all probably don't know what
happened so quickly all right they had a
um a guest come on their pod
asian doll
which is a weird name off the top uh she
came in halfway through the pod she's
late
and her and another person were having a
conversation off the mic a little bit
but still getting picked up myron gets a
little upset guys guys sidebar sidebar
conversations please all right what i've
told you this is like you know this is
like the fifth time i've told you that
right
like stop for real like stop
so how are you gonna come on somebody's
show not know we'll go down and say oh
you're mean it don't matter
so she leaves and the video goes viral
people are coming after them and they
said they hate black women why because
clip surface so let's just play the quit
so the first clip comes out and it's
basically them being asked about a
dating app for black women and they're
like yo listen what about the black dane
app called black
it's funny i never used that one bro but
hey man
i mean hey bro if you want to date a
bunch of shaniquas go for it man
laquisha yeah like
me and fresh aren't really down with the
brown like that we ain't night riders so
i'm good uh you know sometimes if
they're you know red bone but like in
general me and fresh don't dabble in the
dark if you know what i'm saying yeah
and people lost their mind and then
afterwards after the backlash myron's
like listen what's wrong with having a
preference when it comes to dating in
your personal preferences
no one bats an eye when women say i want
a man of six feet tall makes a certain
amount of money blah blah blah those are
considered preferences but if i say hey
man
i don't date black girls like that oh
god you hate black women oh dare you you
know what i'm saying it's ridiculous my
mom's black your mom's black yeah my
sister's black like bro we just have a
preference it's not the same thing
there's a difference between having
preferences
that's one thing and there's another
thing about dissing a [ __ ] when
you're saying i don't want to date
shaniquas
you're not stating your preferences not
mad about your [ __ ] preference
they're mad about you dissing the other
one but hey you know what maybe they
were just joking
maybe they don't have negative opinions
of black ladies okay and they were just
using shaniqua as a joke for humor it's
possible it's possible okay but
then fresh has to open his mouth
i don't know what's wrong with fresh but
this [ __ ] cannot stop taking else okay
listen listen barbados fender i know you
don't you don't clint you don't claim
him i know like just keep it real
i don't really date black girls
it's not because like no no like most
black girls are like annoying how to put
this uh ratchet and they don't know how
to like be reserved you're like the
complete opposite you are not a
stereotype you are not that is not a
compliment all right like i'm when the
[ __ ] tells me oh you're
beautiful for a black man that really
there's a lot it's not just yeah the
person called me beautiful but that's
[ __ ] up that's still [ __ ] up so when
you say no but you're not like that you
really talk like a white tooth oh you're
not like the rest of them naggers
what the [ __ ] bro think about what he
said you're annoying you're not
you're not ratchet right so that's the
perception of life yeah and not
recognizing like there's a variety of
women out there who are black who have a
different experience you don't encounter
them fresh because you live in
nightclubs you live faking your
lifestyle you're stuck constantly around
women who are on ig so of course there's
going to again be a selection bias right
where the only type of women you're
going to meet are ratchets you get what
i'm saying
it's like even though and i think it's
so funny that fresh says this stuff it's
like but the one girl he wanted to wife
out turned out to be a sugar baby who's
coaching men on how to stop coaching
women on how to [ __ ] play men it's
just it's just funny to me that these
guys talk like this
in this house there's some horses
in this house
keywords bring a but i digress high
standards i like i like the way fresh
always comes in
to add a little grain of salt and it
always like
it's perfectly like that
he's a scammer that tells on himself
myra could at least keep up a good
facade yeah he can he can put up a good
projected image fresh is just no like
rough you don't like black women just
say that y'all are ghetto ratchet and
disgusting you smell bad but i don't
have a problem with black what are you
talking about
let any white person talk about black
dudes the same way you would say what
yeah black guys uh you know they're
ratchet they're ghetto they smell bad
and they're unemployable what the [ __ ]
but that's how you think and here's the
thing a lot of people want to be able to
say racist stuff without actually ever
staying or owning the moniker yeah you
know what i'm saying
but you know i know i know he said
something he said to me another man
you're gonna send me back that's another
[ __ ] that a gavin or steven would have
said i'm gonna send you back on your
boat to your country
but you know damn right what the [ __ ]
you was doing talking like a bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] issue
you can say whatever you want you can
say i have a preference for this asian
men black women nothing wrong with that
when you say i wouldn't date black women
because physically they're just not my
type nothing wrong with that
i want to date white women because
culturally it's more in line with me
nothing wrong with them
i don't want to date asians because they
got slanted eyes and honestly they're
too quiet for me and i think they're
kind of losers
do we not see the difference
right people love to masquerade their
negative views about certain groups as a
preference okay
right i remember i remember this i was
dating this white girl okay this was
when i was like about 19.
and we were getting serious it's going
well
and she told me i want you to be my
parents and you already know
deuces
i said sure
and the day before i was supposed to
meet her parents i'm like do they know
i'm black she said no i said
[Music]
what you doing
but that's the thing the privilege
really sometimes prevents you from
seeing those things yes
i'm also like
nick but you know hey
go go to go go i said go tell him she
said nah go i don't know
i said go your parents i'm not gavin
there's a lot of people there's a lot of
people out there
y'all know your parents are racist all
right
and i ain't talking about white people
i'm talking about everybody yes you
don't know your parents are racist until
yes and to be fair
okay
shout out to my mom but hey she'd be
saying some wild things i'd be looking
at her like
okay
yes i don't even whisper it i'm like
that's but i still look cuz your mom
okay
her dad was like eventually her dad came
out and said listen i don't want my
daughter with a black man okay
now
i'm not mad at that
you want your daughter to date a white
dude because culturally whatever cool go
ham she said i want my daughter to date
a black guy because they're ghetto
now do you guys see the difference
can we all understand the difference
now look again
you know
what fresh and fit should have done is
what a lot of the other manosphere guys
do which is like man listen black women
are the worst and i don't recommend
dating them right that's what a lot of
these guys in the atmosphere just
straight up say and i'm not mad at you
at least you're outwardly projecting
your real views and that's cool
but y'all front on that point what do
you think roman dustbands yeah
or what why is it that so many of these
manosphere guys have so many negative
things to say about black women i don't
i don't know
a lot of them do
yeah they do they a lot of them do well
i mean if you look at society i don't
know if you look at society and the way
well a society has been treating black
women you know it's just a general thing
and they amplify it so they're going to
take that and they're going to just
amplify it i believe you know what i
mean we want to hear what you guys think
what do you guys think in the comments
below let us know wanna hear from you